hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt das geht auch besser und heute
machen wir denn ambrosia salat aus
edward mit den scherenhänden
edward mit den scherenhänden ist ein
film von tim burton aus dem jahre 1990
hauptdarsteller also edward ist johnny
depp von dem man ja in letzter zeit ein
bisschen mehr gehört hat was an dem
ganzen prozess liegt gegen seine ex frau
amber heard die sind nämlich ein
bisschen crazy gewesen in ihrer
beziehung wenn man das so sagen kann
sind wirklich komisch schlimme sachen
vorgefallen zu denen ich jetzt gar nicht
stellung beziehen möchte oder mich auf
eine seite schlagen will ich finde beide
parteien haben irgendwo ihre
berechtigung und beide parteien haben
sich wirklich nicht korrekt verhalten
und ich bin aber kein richter oder
anwalt der das richtig einschätzen kann
ich finde die kommentare sind teilweise
sehr hart der amber heard gegenüber
finde aber auch dass vieles ein bisschen
steril und nicht zusammenkommt
um das hier mal ganz kurz zu klären ich
habe zu viel spaß dabei mich wie dem
spiel vorzubereiten aber zurück zum film
edward mit den scherenhänden geht es um
eine kleine vorstadt in amerika an der
ein hügel liegt mit einem großen
gruseligen schlagen in diesem schloss
lebte dort eines tages kommt habe ich
ihren namen vergessen aber die mama in
dem film an dieses schloss rahmen um
make up zu verkaufen denn sie ist eine
vertreterin für make-up und da findet
sie edward und nimmt ihn mit zu sich
nach hause und das sorgt natürlich in
diesem vor ort ganz schön viel aufregung
das wird aber noch nicht zu viel
verraten denn falls wir den film noch
nicht gesehen habe würde ich euch den
empfehlen den gibt es zurzeit auf disney
plus ironic bei johnny depp aber da
könnt ihr euch den anschauen und ansonst
beim hat den glaube ich für drei euro
zum ausleihen und vielleicht habt ihr
den ja auch auf dvd oder video kassette
von euren eltern wer weiß was ich aber
verraten kann ist wo diese am großer
salat vorkommen die familie bock lädt
alle nachbarn typisch amerikanisch zum
barbecue an und da kommt auch die
nachbarin joyce die so ein bisschen ich
würde mal sagen notgeil ist und später
auch ziemlich fragwürdige dinge tut die
überhaupt nicht okay sind aber in dieser
szene hat sie ihren ambrose salat
mitgebrachte den hat sie ganz speziell
für edward gemacht und gibt ihnen einen
löffel davon in den mund und weil es ja
ein barbecue ist dachte ich diese am bio
salat ist vielleicht so ein eiersalat
kartoffelsalat hat irgend etwas
herzhaftes es stellt sich raus ein
ambrosia salat ist ein typisch
amerikanisches oder
südamerikanisches gericht also süd usa
nicht südamerika sondern süd usa die
auswanderin ananas nüssen und
marshmallows besteht ich weiß die
amerikaner lieben ihre süßigkeiten aber
das ist wirklich
das klingt interessant und hat sich das
gehört habe dachte ich ja gut dann ist
das wahrscheinlich ein obstsalat ein
nachtisch das wird einfach so als
beilage zu fleisch oder grill zeug
serviert amerikanische rezepte sind
bestimmt super toll aber sie machen mir
echt zu viele marsch - über rein
zufällig gewinnen gibt es glaube ich aus
mesh potato süßkartoffel 3 mit drauf ich
hab noch nie so richtig traditionelle
amerikanische gegessen außer bürger und
fried chicken mit grafites aber ja und
bevor ich euch jetzt weiter mit meinen
scherenhänden auf den geist gehen wir
sie aus und fangen an zu kochen und die
zutaten für einen ambrose salat sind
schmand und sahne marshmallows
kokosraspeln mandarin alles ja es muss
aus der dose sein es kann natürlich auch
frisch sein aber aus der dose ist ein
bisschen lila schwarz kirchen und
cocktail kirchen puderzucker extrakt er
muss natürlich von sally sein wissen
lebensmittelfarbe und zum servieren
cracker dazu ihre cracker sehen ein
bisschen anders aus ein bisschen dünner
aber das sind halt die einzigen träger
die ich gefunden haben ich glaube
wir haben hier ein amerikanisches rezept
deswegen brauchen wir wachsen hier ist
ein cup hier haben wir ein viertel kein
halten gab und ein drittel cup ist ja
eigentlich ganz einfach dass in
amerikanischen rezepten sondern wie
fühlst du dich als kamerafrau und mein
arm wird langsam
jetzt erst mal mit der sahne
angeschlagen werden in amerika benutzen
sie ganz gerne herr wie cream das ist so
eine
japanerin leid aber wir haben in
deutschland keine heavy krimis wegen
plötzlicher sahne denn fett ist gut so
dafür nehmen wir unseren mixa 3000 das
ist typisch amerikanisch das würde in
den film rein passen und die wird jetzt
[Musik]
die sache ist wertet hier rein kommt
jetzt der schwand das wird quasi ein
halber seiner
amerikanische rezept schreibt sour cream
aber deren zahl ist nicht unsere server
kriegen das ist er zu vergleichen mit
schmand es folgt nun ein viertel cup
oder zucker und er kommt in unsere
schöne masse mit
einem extrakt bereite lassen sich lohnen
das sieht toll aus nennt sich doch noch
kochen aus und vor irgend jetzt
miteinander konnte sie
das tun jetzt anderen kühlschrank und
kümmern uns um den rest ich kann mich
einfach nicht also ich kann mich mit dem
gedanken anfreunden dass das wirklich zu
tat sein soll es werden sogar bunte
marshmallow gewaltsam bruch liga
schmeckt lecker der sprecher auch ein
paar andere
man leute da ist doch pervers
was willst du mehr ich habe gefragt was
du bist ein maßnahmen auf die
[Musik]
gedanken
wir haben jetzt nicht ein cup nicht zwei
sondern vier cups marshmallows rhein ist
die beilage für haupt gerichtet
jetzt wird es gesund alle rezepte sagen
dass man gesüßte kokosraspeln braucht
wir haben ungesüßter weil wir einfach
keine gesüßten so wirklich in
deutschland haben oder ich muss nur ein
spezieller laden zeigen und von unseren
ungesüßten trade coconuts brauchen wir
an ein halb caps und das haben wir
miteinander ist daraus als ob das kind
in der küche kochen spielen
[Musik]
als jetzt kann man sie manchmal gehen
also leute ich habe ja schon mal den
sieben geschichten seiner art gemacht
und da habe ich nun wirklich große
portion gemacht ich habe aus dieser
situation gelernt und ich werde jetzt
nur die halbe portion macht sieht am
ende vielleicht nicht so schön aus aber
wenn ich schon wieder sehe was ich hier
da zusammen wechselnd meist tierhalter
gehört für die halbe portion entschieden
haben nehmen wir eine dose mondory auf
dem fuß umgeknickt
[Applaus]
und die kommen jetzt in unsere schlüssel
rein
als nächstes folgt unser an assen ist
professionell so trifft man in sachen an
die geräuschkulisse pipi machen und das
hört sich jetzt anders als wenn zwei
menschen liege machen heißt sie sind ein
bisschen zusätzlich
sowie mag man seine ananasstückchen
nicht so groß nicht zu klein
ja klar ist so ein stück an ist
kameramann fütterung kamerafrau foto
rein
wir kommen zu den cocktail
kirchenkritischen sind sehr kontrovers
manche linke sie manche hassen sie finde
ich meinen aber noch marzipan deswegen
finde ich sie sogar
aber starke zu nehmen wir einen drittel
kock den kirchen trost eine art die so
in
die hälfte glaube ich
klebrig und im video
ok
in vielen rezepten werden auch noch
nüsse vorgeschlagen flüsse sind gesund
und da kann man die nutzen nehmen die
man möchte pkw sind sehr beliebt in
amerika schon mit einer handvoll
technisch und die caches schneiden wir
einfach eine kleine stücke hat die kam
zu unserer mischung dazu das besondere
an jobs an browsers erlitt ist dass der
so eine hink lila farbe hat den haben
normale ambrosia scouts nicht vermute
dass sie auch dunkle kirchen reingemacht
hat wie diese hier schwarz kirschen wir
nehmen sie ein ganz bisschen davon und
gucken mal was damit der farbe ansonsten
zum nachfärben nehmen wir dann einfach
den saft spielt also oder nehme ich mir
mal ein
paar kerzen einfach nur dass es seine
farbe abgeben kann geschmack ist
bestimmt auch gut und es kommen will
[Musik]
gute training gute creme da muss von
dieser sehr geilen cremen die hälfte und
geben sie an zu
kribbeln mit rein
das wird gerührt leute denn ambrosia
skelett leute ich hab mir nur zehn
mitglieder osten schließlich kam noch
mal gut dass wir dies war nämlich ein
bisschen man sagen cremiger glauben wir
können über mehrere machen
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen was von ihm sagt denn die farbe
stimmt noch nicht
als
lausannes recht ziemlich gut oder es
wird empfohlen den einmal über nacht
stehen zu lassen damit alle zutaten sich
gut entfalten können oder ein paar
stunden bevor man ihn serviert ich werde
jetzt nicht mehrere stunden warten aber
so eine gute stunde lasse ich dem jetzt
und dann eine mit 37 kindern schmeckt
und zum probieren dachte ich verwandle
ich mich mal in kehlen in sie verliebt
sich etwas und ich hab noch blaue sahne
obendrauf gemacht also ich hab die sahne
noch mal blau eingefärbt um drauf
gemacht und so sieht es dann halt
wirklich aus wie von joiz ich leider
keine so coole halterungen an meiner
schüssel wie joyce aber und nun stellen
wir uns die allerwichtigste frage wie
schmeckt der ambrosia salad von joyce
aus edward mit den scherenhänden der
geruch ist
fragwürdig angesagt es riecht ganz gut
ich finde es riecht irgendwie
riecht also ja ich meine im film sieht
auch so aus ungefähr ich habe den luxus
nicht ganz eins zu eins hingekriegt aber
ungefähr so kann man das vorstellen
bisschen glaube seine natürlich letzt
schweiz ich habe so etwas in meinem
leben noch nie gegessen ich bin so
gespannt
[Musik]
moment umschwenkt nicht ganz gut
die marshmallows sind immer noch komisch
weil der geschmack ist wirklich an
slacker also man schmeckt halt die
ananas und die mandarin und des kokons
und irgendwie herr
marshmallows halten ich würde diesen
salat nicht als beilage essen aber so
als dass er so eine kleine portion ist
gar nicht mal so schlecht
probiert ihn mal ausmacht immer selber
das ist ein ganz lecker ich habe aber
auch grafiken haben falls sie diesen
salat ist unbedingt mal nachmachen
wollte ich verlinke euch das rezept und
in der video beschreibung und besinnung
sondern das nächste mal wieder natürlich
auch noch mit dem trecker probieren
an kleine ergänzung ich habe jetzt ja
ein bisschen was von diesem salat
gegessen ist ziemlich schlecht geworden
wenn wir bis an den marshmallows liegt
oder an der kombination aber hass auf
wenn ihr diesen salat macht die ersten
löffel sind ganz lecker ja und dann wird
einem schlecht sahen